في جنيف خصصت الامم المتحده هذا الاجتماع
لاوكرانيا لمناقشه المساعدات واوضاع
المدنيين بعد ان قدم منسق الشؤون
الانسانيه في الامم المتحده وقائع عن
الوضع في اوكرانيا للتذكير بالتكلفه
الباهظه لهذه الحرب على المدنيين سيحتاج
40% من السكان الى مساعدات انسانيه هذا
العام نزح 4 ملايين شخص داخليا بينما يعيش
اكثر من 3ه ملايين على الخطوط الاماميه
للحرب المنافسه لايجاد تمويل هذا العام
ستكون اكثر صعوبه من العام الماضي الامم
المتحده اعلنت انها بحاجه الى اربعه
مليارات و2 مليون دولار لعام
2024 لتوفير مساعدات انسانيه داخل
اوكرانيا ولمسا عده اللاجئين خارجها اكثر
من ست ملايين اوكراني تركوا بلادهم تريد
الامم المتحده الحصول على تبرعات تزيد عن
ثلاثه مليارات دولار لداخل اوكرانيا
وغيرها للاجئين نطلب ما يزيد قليلا عن
مليار دولار من اجل اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
والمجتمعات المضيفه طلبنا العام الماضي
مبالغ اكبر من هذا العام تعمل الحكومات
والمفوض الاوروبيه بشكل اكبر لهذا هناك
حاجه اقل لنا ولشركات الامم المتحده قررت
تخفيض حجم المساعدات لهذه السنه واختارت
التركيز على الاحتياجات الطارئه بشكل اكبر
اجتمعت اكثر من 80 دوله في دافوس في
سويسرا في الجوله الرابعه من مفاوضات
قائمه على اقتراحات لفلاديمير زيلينسكي
لايجاد صيغه للسلام في اوكرانيا فيها
مستشارون للامن القومي دون مشاركه روسيا
انها نقاشات لا يمكن ان تهدف الى التوصل
الى نتيجه محدده لسبب واضح وبسيط وهو اننا
لا نشارك فيها الرئيس الاوكراني يشارك
ايضا في المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في
دافوس لمناقشه الاوضاع في اوكرانيا